[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello martin how are you
doing
same as yesterday and i hope again that
that was good
well let's say it was hectic
so it's still going hectic yes it's
always hectic
that's why we need lord so much you know
i was thinking
we at episode 59
if the people if the viewers can just
understand
that everything is 100
the holy spirit in god because
it's impossible to do what we do and
how it comes together nobody can say
and sometimes we are almost at the point
of despair
and sometimes we say no we're not going
to do that
and we always end up doing it what's
wrong with you yeah
so what's wrong with me i don't know why
we always put our foot in it yeah
and that's why we want to give all the
glory to god
nothing can come from us we're just
vehicles
absolutely we're nothing god is very
good to us
let's thank you our heavenly father
thank you so much for using us
and thank you so much for everything
that you do for us
we ask again please help us through this
most important discussion
enlighten our minds and bless us and
bless the viewers in jesus name
amen
now martin i have always
tried to avoid this issue
because it is such a controversial issue
and the opinions are so
strong out there that
any deviation from
what one group thinks or the other group
thinks puts you in the firing line
and it is an interesting fact in the
world
that the issue that we're going to talk
about today
has caused more blood to flow
than probably any other millions
and millions have died in conflicts
about things that we are going to talk
about
now god never intended it like that
because god is a god of love and a god
of mercy
but the devil intends it yeah because
he's at war with god
so the topic we are going to talk about
is the doctrine of the law
predestination and christian perfection
and not only is this a topic
that has been debated extensively
in the course of history this is a topic
that is hotly debated
in every denomination
and that includes our own correct
and there are distinct parties
that are absolutely at loggerheads
regarding this issue so this is nothing
new
so sometimes one thinks you know maybe
we should just sit on the fence
and see who says what and to whom
and how does this pan out but sometimes
it comes to the point where you can no
longer do that
because the issue becomes public you say
one little word
somewhere and people misconstrue it
if you take the side of
grace and grace alone
then you are branded
as a person that says do what thou wilt
is the whole of the law
yes if you take the side of no
you have to do what is right you are
branded as a legalist
and never the twin shall meet
and so right from the start let us
ask or let us request
that we give each other space
not everybody is going to see this in
the same way
and not everybody is going to be happy
to
compromise on a point of view or to
let's not use the word compromise it's
probably not a good word
let us say allow for someone else to
have another opinion
many people this issue is so black or so
white
that there cannot be a shade of gray
and uh i would like to appeal to
everyone
to give each other space
and if someone sees it differently
then where are our points of contact now
this is not
something that can be an economical
discussion
where you must reach a compromise truth
must never be compromised
but there were differences of opinion
amongst the early disciples
and so there will be differences of
opinion at the end of time as well
but we must learn to tolerate
another's position if it does
not go against the direct explicit
word of god so let's talk about the
doctrine of the law predestination and
christian perfection
and the let's do it very
prayerfully yes in the bible it says
we have to be of one accord correct but
that doesn't mean that everybody have to
be
exactly the same no you don't have to
see it exactly the same in fact there
were
very heated debates in the early church
and
separations even on that basis
but we must be of one accord
and one mission yes and we mustn't end
up
being at war with each other because
we have a commission to spread the
gospel
we don't have a commission to tear each
other to shreds
let's look at this very important
situation
and ask for a little bit of patience by
everyone
and serious contemplation
and if my view or our view that we
express
is not exactly the same as your view
then let us give each other space
because nobody is trying to
develop an apostate doctrine we are all
just trying to understand
the issue from the roots upwards
correct yes and for that we need the
holy spirit amen
and we need it because we know that
there's a war
in this world regarding this issue yes
1 john 3 verse 4 says whoever committeth
sin transgresses also the law
for sin is the transgression
of the law
that is the basis for the doctrine of
sin
now we read here in the book faith and
works
now we want to understand what sin is
it is what that
it is the transgression of
god's law this is the
only definition given in the scriptures
let me just stop there there are
many apparent definitions
of sin in the bible if you do not
believe in christ
that is determined to be sin
of sin because they believe not in me
right correct
but if you boil it down to the very
basis you will
always find that it comes back to the
law of the law correct
so the only definition that we really
have
in the scripture is that sin is the
transgression
of the law as we discussed in a previous
one some people say sin is separation
from god
but we read very distinctly in that one
in the book of isaiah
no your sin has separated you
from your god so what is sin it is the
transgression of the law
therefore we see that those who claim to
be led of god
and go right away from him and his law
do not search the scriptures but the
lord will lead his people for he says
that his sheep will follow
if they hear his voice but a stranger
will they not follow then it becomes us
to thoroughly understand the scriptures
and we will not have to inquire whether
others have the truth
for it will be seen in their characters
so obviously this truth must have an
outworking
in attitude right yes it must
be apparent in the character correct you
must live it out
exactly all right so that's the basis
and it's a biblical basis
that is the definition
now three times in the king james
version
we find this little sentence say no more
and the first one we find in jeremiah
chapter 31 verse 34
and here it refers to sin as a noun
and this is something that god will do
concerning this issue called
sin which is transgression of the law
okay
and they shall teach no more every man
his neighbor
and every man is brother saying know the
lord
for they shall all know me from the
least of them
unto the greatest of them says the lord
for i will forgive their iniquity
and i will remember their sin
no more
so god is going to remove
this burden of sin under certain
conditions
he's going to do it and he's going to do
it
it is his work this is the basis
of the plan of salvation
now this this sentence sin no more
we also find it in the new testament not
as a noun
but as a verb as something to do yes
so here jesus healed
this individual and afterward jesus
findeth him in the temple and said unto
him
behold thou art made whole
sin no more lest the worst thing
come upon thee here is an instruction
and the instruction to this individual
who was physically healed
is sin no more
in john 8 11 we have the woman that was
caught in adultery
and the accusers left after jesus had
written in the sand
and she said to his question where are
your accusers
she says no man lord there's nobody here
to accuse me anymore
and jesus said unto her neither do i
condemn thee
and then comes the injunction go
and sin no more
now when you analyze that verse you will
find that in this verse
we have both the elements of
justification
and sanctification all right
neither do i condemn thee that's
forgiveness yes
grace and justification
go and sin no more that's sanctification
yes now is this a request or is this an
instruction instructions
instruction are you sure yes
so if you know what the definition of
sin is
then rephrase this for me
then go and keep the whole of the law
that's exactly what he says right then
keep the law
okay now if jesus gives an instruction
keep the law uh is it then
according to the instruction possible to
carry it out
yes should be right now
we have so many religions in the world
that say nobody can keep the law
yes but this is at loggerheads with the
instruction
go and sin no more right
we have so many people that say
that because it's impossible to keep the
law god actually got rid of the law
correct and that is a huge chunk of
christianity that teaches that correct
yes
and the statements that we've just made
a lot of people will now say there you
go again now you're legalists
but we're just reading the scriptures
you're just reading the scripture that's
what
have to be kept in mind and we must
study the scripture
because this is the very basis of the
plan of salvation
this is the important issue
so the question i have is how would they
be
enabled to go answer no more
and that is where it comes now in
before you accuse somebody of being a
legalist for quoting that verse
study it through this exactly so
how does it work now here's a statement
in the great controversy
satan assailed christ with his fiercest
and most
subtle temptations but he was repulsed
in every conflict
those battles were fought in our
behalf those victories
make it possible for us to conquer
christ will give strength to all who
seek it so how are you enabled
through christ christ will give strength
to all who seek it is there something
that you must do
you must seek him you must seek it
no man without his own consent can be
overcome by satan
the tempter has no power to control the
will
so does the world play an important part
yes yes
or to force the soul to sin he may
distress
but he cannot contaminate he can cause
agony but not defilement
the fact that christ has conquered
should inspire his followers with
courage to fight
manfully the battle against sin and
satan now if we go to one john 2 verse 4
he says
i know him and keepeth not his
commandments
is a liar and the truth is not
in him so when jesus said go
and sin no more he was not
instructing an impossibility
in fact he goes so far here through the
disciple john
to say that if you do not follow the
instruction
you're actually a liar if you say that
you know jesus
this is scripture the scripture we're
not making this up
right and already we are in trouble yes
so no matter what we do on this issue
we're going to be in trouble right yes
but this is what the scriptures teach
the scripture is very clear on what sin
is and jesus is very clear that you must
break with sin
and the scripture is very clear that if
you do not
follow this then you are lying when you
say
you're a christian yes here's another
quote
from the great controversy let none
deceive themselves with the belief
that they can become holy while
willfully
violating one of god's requirements
the commission of a known sin silences
the witnessing voice of the spirit
and separates the soul from god
so what separates lawful sin
willful sin did adam and eve commit a
willful sin yes yes
they did were there consequences yes
they were separated right yeah so where
they
first separated and then committed to
sin or first committed to sin and then
separated first committed
okay sin is the transgression of the law
and whoever sinneth transgresses the law
has not seen him neither known him
quoting 1 john 3
6 though john in his epistles dwells so
fully upon the love
yet he does not hesitate to reveal the
true character of that class who claim
to be sanctified
while living in the transgression of the
law of god
he that says i know him and keepeth not
his commandments is a liar and the truth
is not in him but whosoever keepeth his
word
in him verily the love of god is
perfected 1 john
2 verse 4 and 5. here is the test of
every man's profession we cannot
accord holiness to any man
without bringing him to the measurement
of god's only standard of holiness
in heaven and in earth if men feel no
weight
of the moral law if they belittle and
make
light of god's precepts if they break
one of the least of these commandments
and teach men
so they shall be of no
esteem in the sight of heaven and we may
know
that their claims are without foundation
now that's not an arbitrary statement
that's a quote from the scriptures jesus
said i did not come to abolish the law
not one jot or one tittle will by no
means disappear from the lord
if you love me keep my commandments so
this is very scriptural so far
so we cannot negate the basis
and the foundation which is being laid
here in the scriptures
regarding the law of god here's another
quote from the review in herald only by
accepting the virtue
and grace of christ can the law be kept
that's a very important statement now
this is now touching on
the crux of the matter and here is the
difference between
legalism and faith correct
as soon as you're saying well i've i've
got it
i've got it all together that's legalism
but when you are totally dependent on
the virtue and grace of christ
then you are operating on the basis of
faith
yes so belief in the propitiation
for sin that means the price that was
paid at the cross
enables fallen man to love god with his
whole heart
and his neighbor as himself
so they have the classic example in the
bible
of the pharisee and the publican and the
pharisees said
i'm so glad i'm not like that guy over
there
lord i do this i do that i
pay tithe and do everything that is
required
and i'm such a good citizen
and the other one says lord i am a
sinner
which one went home justified yeah this
republican republican went down
knowledge that he's a sinner
so this one was pushing out his chest
and had there been any buttons on them
they would have popped off
and the other one beat his chest into a
pulp
yeah so this one was the one that was
justified
so this tells us that uh
even though there is this command
go and sin no more it is
enabled yes by the power of christ
christ
i was just looking at that quote again
it enables fallen man to love god with
his whole heart and his neighbor as
himself
on this two commands on this
hangs the whole of the law correct you
must love god and you must love your
neighbor
so actually that can also say enables
fallen man to love god
and keep his law yes galatians chapter 3
verse 2
tells us this only would i learn of you
received ye the spirit by the works of
the law
or by the hearing of faith it's a
rhetorical question
obviously he didn't receive it by the
works of the law
but by faith verse 22
says but the scripture has concluded all
under sin that the promise by faith
of jesus christ might be given to them
that
believe so it is
always by faith correct
and romans 14 verse 23 puts it very
succinctly and whatever is not of faith
is sin so there's another definition of
sin
in other words what he's saying here if
we redefine it whatever is not of faith
is transgression of the law
around 100 so that's what it says right
yes
okay so this should tell you
already from the start that
we have nothing to boast about and
any form of legalism is an affront to
god
so the only way to approach this is by
acknowledgement i am a sinner yes
repentance acceptance
of the sacrifice by faith you are taking
responsibility
and then giving god permission
to change you correct and that is an act
of the will and it is your personal
choice now this is a very important
issue can god
tell you to keep the law
if you are not capable of keeping the
law
no then it's a futile instruction right
yeah
and this debate has been raging in the
christian
world ever since its inception
exactly well it can probably come from
adam and eve
yes now martin luther in the reformation
having come out of a church that was so
works driven
came to a conclusion that we are
justified by faith alone
and this is this is
the central part of the religious system
as he explains it so martin luther of
his article
justification by faith alone says
nothing can be yielded or surrendered
nothing nor can anything be granted or
permitted contrary to the same
this is the first in the chief article
this is his article on the issue
then he states if the article of
justification is lost
all christian doctrine is lost at the
same
time this doctrine justification
is the head and the cornerstone it
alone begets nourishes builds
preserves and defends the church of god
and without it the church of god cannot
exist for one hour
when the article of justification has
fallen
everything has fallen
now justification by faith
alone so it's something that i can grab
hold of
only through faith there's nothing i can
do
to attain it and justification
is a legal term it has the word
justice in it so if you are
justified then there
is a justice that is imputed
but as martin luther explained it is an
alien just justification it's not
your justice it comes from god
so you are justified by christ
it doesn't become yours it is
always his that is imputed
to you and you obtain it by faith
and it is a legal concept
it's not something you can work towards
no it either exists or it does
not exist
now the other side of the coin is the
epistle of james and
luther in the beginning when he
discovered the doctrine of justification
was so overwhelmed by this
immense load that fell from his
shoulders
because his church taught
justification by works yes the poor man
had whipped himself into a frazzle
and had lane for hours trying to get rid
of the burden of guilt
and then he realized but he'll never do
it and then he discovered that
the justice of jesus christ and the
righteousness of jesus christ can be
imputed to him as if it were his own
it was such a relief and then when he
read james he started to sweat again
because james in verse
17 of chapter 2 says even so faith
if it has not works is dead being alone
but wilt thou know o vain man
that faith without works is dead
in verse 26 for as the body without the
spirit is dead so
faith without works is dead also
so in other words what james is saying
is
you start off with faith
but faith has a consequence yes
and that consequence is works yes
now martin luther struggled with this
because he was so enthusiastic about
justification that he called james the
epistle of straw
but he still included it in his bible
translation but he was muttering and
grumbling about it
and then there's this interesting story
in history
where his biographer wrote the following
luther's great biographer
roland benton pointed out once luther
remarked
that he would give his doctor's beret to
anyone who could reconcile
james and paul because paul said
you are justified by faith alone and not
by works
yet he did not venture to reject james
from the canon of scripture
and on occasion earned his own beret
by effecting reconciliation
faith he wrote is a living
restless thing it cannot be
in operative for we are not saved by
works but if there be no works
there must be something amiss with faith
isn't that beautiful it's beautiful all
right so that's what he stated he
reconciled them
but there were still some things
that were lacking in his thinking
in terms of the issue of faith and works
and you know the roman catholic church
has
made it appear that they were for works
and the protestants were for
faith and justification by faith but
actually you know let's put them
together and we'll be fine we'll come
together again
but that's not true and i've given many
many lectures on this
because they don't believe in the
atonement
correct they don't believe jesus died
for you they don't believe that he died
for you
he died and he set an example but he
didn't die for you
but our faith must be in the blood
in the atonement correct so this is a
very very complex
issue and the world is still arguing
about it to this day now
calvin believed in predestination
in other words god is the author of
everything and god
predetermines everything and everything
is in the will of god so
god predetermined that there would be a
fall
yeah and he predetermined who will be
saved and who will be lost
now you get various grades within
calvinism where some will say
that god created adam to fall
others won't go quite that far but the
idea
is god is sovereign you are what you
are and you are basically lost
but god can predestine you to be saved
and there's really nothing that you can
do nothing
yeah so you don't have free will there
is no free will it doesn't exist
so i just wanted to clarify that is what
calvin said that's what calvin said yes
so here you have an interesting cartoon
where you have martin luther and calvin
and both of them are pulling the ears of
the papacy so they had a common enemy
yes they agreed on who the antichrist
was and where the problem was
but martin luther is pulling the beard
of calvin here
he doesn't agree with calvin so this
issue
has been there from the beginning and
they are at loggerheads with one another
but they do rely on the scriptures
and this again tells us that you must
read the scriptures very carefully
otherwise you could take one position
and the other one take the other
position and never the twin shall meet
and there's a there's a middle path
of where they are reconciling but
everybody is on the side tracks exactly
did martin luther
reconcile with the book of james yes
yes he did but he still had this concept
that humanity was basically not totally
capable of doing anything
in total depravity
now if we go back in history and find
out where this all comes from
we have to go back to the early church
now here's a prescribed book in many
universities in the world today
and it's the story of christian theology
20 centuries of tradition and reform
and it's by roger altson
now in the story of christian theology
20 centuries of tradition and reform by
roger olsen
we read the interesting facts that
augustine
and thomas aquinas were church fathers
of the roman catholic church
were steeped in greek philosophy
concerning their doctrine of god and
their
influence has been far reaching in
christianity as a whole
the doctrine of predestination as
espoused by
calvin was largely influenced by the
philosophy of
augustine now let me just stop
there martin luther was an augustinian
monk
so he was also very steeped in the
doctrine of
augustine so this impressed their minds
and there are many many issues that
pertain to augustine that are still held
by
protestants and catholics in the world
today
just for example a millennialism
it's part of the catholic doctrine it's
part of the lutheran doctrine
so if we go further in the doctrine of
augustine
freedom not to sin does not exist
since he believed in unconditional
election
and irresistible christ
now all of these are alive
and well and deaf and living
in different factions of christianity
today
there are many that say we're not
capable of keeping the law of god
we are have no freedom not to sin
we are sinners and thank god god is the
god of love and grace
and so we will just continue with our
activities as before and god will take
care of it
are there many like that yes have you
been through some of those modern
yes god knows my heart so don't judge me
okay and then he believed in
unconditional election
that is saying that you don't have a
choice
if god selected you you won't be able to
not go to heaven that's calvinism today
that's a very large faction and even
within denominations
there are different groupings in certain
denominations
that believe one side or the other side
or a compromise between the two
it gets very complicated i have a
lecture series which is called
conflict and triumph and if people
want more information then they can look
at that series
correct and then the the the
concept of irresistible grace
now these three have caused
major consternation in the world today
and it's been progressive so where does
augustine and thomas aquinas come upon
their
their way of thinking right well we read
in the great controversy this
compromise between paganism and
christianity
resulted in the development of the man
of sin
foretold in prophecy as opposing and
exalted himself above
god that gigantic system of false
religion
is a masterpiece of satan's power
a monument of his efforts to seat
himself
upon the throne to rule the earth
according to his will
roman catholicism is so broad
that it is capable of absorbing
all of these philosophies so they can
say that we can absorb you if you want
to be
saved in your sin and we can absorb
you if you want to be saved by your
works yes
but if you want to be saved from your
sin
then you have a problem with that system
now the paganism that was absorbed is of
course greek philosophy
and the immortality of the soul played a
massive role in that
and if you are immortal well then the
wages of sin are not death no
so the whole doctrine of sin falls apart
correct
when you come to the doctrine of
immortality
so martin if you if you look at this
gigantic
system of false religion the bible
depicts it
as this beast this conglomerate beast
this chimera and the bulk of the body
is a leopard so the bulk
of the philosophy is greek philosophy
roman catholicism both in the doctrines
of
augustine and in the doctrines of
thomas thomas aquinas are greek
philosophy
the system upon which they base their
system
is of course the feet of the bear that's
meter per
person philosophy and then
it has the mouth of the lion the way in
which it presents
its religion to the people is through
babylonian religion
correct baal worship bible worship and
the media persians
that's mitra that's mitra that's sun
worship and that you showed
in your nahim presentation
correct now the horns of course
are roman so
this gives us its power and great
authority
so this authoritative beast is a
masterpiece
it's a conglomerate that can absorb any
false religion
in the entire world yeah even paganism
so
it can it's any religion what is this
new world religion that they're working
together for
well it can fit into that system any
religion can fit into that system
except one if you want to be saved
from yeah your sins
so now this doctrine of predestination
they use the verses in romans
for whom he also did for no it says in
romans 8 from verse 29
he also did predestinate to be conformed
to the image of his son
that he might be the firstborn amongst
many brethren
moreover whom he did predestinate
then he also called and whom he called
them he also justified and whom he
justified
then he also glorified
so now here they're using the
foreknowledge
of god as a decree
that you are being predestined
to either go to hell or to go to heaven
if you have been predestinated for
damnation
then that is your right deserved because
you're a sinner
if you are predestinated to go to heaven
then that is the irresistible grace that
god
gives you you will conform to him
whether you are you like it or not if
you
got no choice you have no choice because
you have no free will
you cannot choose not to sin so
therefore
this is all god's working so basically
you can say
sit back relax be happy and
see which side the chips fall
and this debate was raging the armenian
debate
in in the calvinistic circles the
separation of
of uh this thinking pattern it's all
in that series conflict and triumph
is that we spoke about earlier
now i'm going to skip all that and we'll
just jump to what
wesley had to say on the issue because
once this had
gone all the way and the various
denominations in the world
had settled on the question some for
this position
some for that position wesley came
and he stirred the pot again now
this is on predestination by john wesley
and i think we should read it because he
has such amazing thoughts
he said as all time with
everything that exists therein is
present with him at
once so he sees at once
this is talking about god
whatever was is or will be
to the end of time but observe
we must not think they are because he
knows them
no he knows them because they are
now he's referring to predestination so
just because he knows what your choices
will be
doesn't mean that he actually made your
choice for you
no this is what he's saying just as
i if one may be allowed to compare the
things of men with the deep things of
god
now know the sun shines yet the sun does
not shine because i know it
but i know it because he shines
my knowledge supposes the sun to shine
but does not in any ways
cause it in like manner
god knows that man sins for he knows all
things
yet we do not sin because he knows it
correct that's very important
but he knows it because we sin
and his knowledge supposes our sin
but does not in any wise cause it
in a word god looking on all ages from
the creation
to the consummation as a moment and
seeing at once whatever
is in the hearts of the children of men
knows
everyone that does or does not believe
in every age or nation yet what he knows
whether faith or unbelief is in no
wise caused by his knowledge
men are as free in believing or not
believing
as if he did not know it at all
all right so he's making an argument
and he's saying predestination
is diabolical
in fact he goes so far as to say it
makes god worse than the devil because
then he becomes
not only the author of evil
but he will condemn you to eternal
suffering
even though you had no choice in the
matter right
so it actually created you to die
it created you to die and suffer
or created you to experience eternal
bliss
purely based upon his choice and not
yours
but jesus said neither do i condemn
you go and sin no more there's your
choice
and in the book of ezekiel it says if
the wicked man turns from his wickedness
none of his forward
wickedness will be remembered he will be
declared righteous right and if the
righteous man turns from his
righteousness none of his former
righteousness will
be remembered he will certainly die so
joshua says tuesday this day whom you
will serve
so these are so many things that are
confusing
he continues to say indeed if man were
not free
he could not be accountable either for
his thoughts
word or actions if he were not free
he would not be capable either of reward
or punishment he would be incapable
either of virtue or vice of being either
morally good or bad
if he had no more freedom than the sun
the moon or the stars
he would be no more accountable
than them on supposition
that he had no more freedom than them
the stones of the earth would be
as capable of reward as liable to
punishment
as man one would be as accountable as
the other yea
and it would be as absurd to ascribe
either virtue or vice to him as to
ascribe it to the stock of a tree
martin do you agree with that yes it's
logic right yeah
so if you don't have a choi choice in
the matter
and the table doesn't have a choice in
the matter you're on the same ground
absolutely all right so we can
concur with the thinking of wesley right
and in fact seventh-day adventism when
it comes to this doctrine
is basically on the same page as
the method this song but to proceed
whom he did for no then he did
predestinate to be conformed to the
image of the son
is quoting scripture this is the second
step
to speak after the manner of men for in
fact there is
nothing before or after in god
in other words god decrees from
everlasting to everlasting that all
who believe in the son of his love
shall be conformed to his image
shall be saved from all inward and
outward sin
into all inward and outward holiness
accordingly it is a plain
undeniable fact all who truly believe in
the name of the son of god
do now receive the end of their faith
the salvation of their souls and this
in virtue of the unchangeable
irreversible
irresistible decree of god he that
believeth
shall be saved he that believeth not
shall be
damned now if you just
stopped there you would again run into
the debate do we have to now keep the
law or not
but if you take it to its logical
consequence you would have to agree
that if you make the choice then you
must come into harmony with god's will
again right
so what did wesley believe on this issue
and what does his church believe
let's just go there the methodist belief
regarding the law
this handwriting of ordinances our lord
did blot
out take away and nail it to the cross
colossians 2 14
but the moral law contained in the ten
commandments and enforced by the
prophets he did not take
away so in other words they believe
that the law spoken about in colossians
that was nailed to the cross was the
ceremonial law
but it in no way affected the model law
of ten commandments
so they claim that the moral law stands
on an
entirely different foundation from the
ceremonial or ritual law
every part of this law must remain in
force
upon all mankind and in all ages
so this is what john wesley said
therefore the law stands
[Music]
now under calvinism it's very
easy to say the lord does not stand
because you're predestined so we have
factions in calvinism that say the law
stands and in fact they read the law
every sunday from the pulpit but there
are many subgroups that have developed
out of them that say the law is gone
we don't have to keep the law and then
there are subgroups that say keeping the
law is a sin
that's a total reversal right yeah
that's sounding
like the devil
his argument it sounds like his argument
because the bible clearly says
sin is transgression of the law and
they're saying
keeping the law is sin isn't that's that
doesn't make any sense
in fact they go this fine say no
christian
whatsoever is free from the obedience of
the commandments which are called moral
now if that is the case one wonders why
they stop at nine but let's not
not go there now if we want to
understand this doctrine
of the basis of sin and we're
we're heading towards christian
perfection right which is a
real bone of contention then
only in the light of the sanctuary
can the doctrine of salvation be
understood
and that is why the sanctuary message
is of such paramount importance
and it seems to me that most of
christianity
has just lost sight of it they don't
know
what stan what it's about
because most of christianity
sees it it's in the old testament
so it's not applicable but jesus said
quite plainly whatever is written in the
old testament testifies of him
of him so this is something that we need
to study
and if you read the book of hebrews
it's all about the sanctity and it is
the application
of the sanctuary message and it talks
about the high priest that has entered
into the heavenly sanctuary
not bad by human hands but one that was
constructed by god
and therefore it's important to
understand the earthly ministry
in order to understand the heavenly
ministry right great
now what is the sanctuary all about what
happened in the old testament
well the whole message of the sanctuary
was the solution to sin
jesus christ correct everything pointed
in the whole
absolutely everything so when we study
this sanctuary message then
we are actually studying the plan of
redemption yes so let's read the
statement in the great controversy
all who have received the light upon
these subjects
are to bear testimony of the great
truths
which god has committed to them the
sanctuary in heaven
is the very center of christ's work in
behalf of men
it concerns every soul living upon the
earth it opens to view the plan of
redemption
bringing us down to the very close of
time and revealing the triumphant
issue of the contest between
righteousness and
sin it is of the utmost
importance that all should thoroughly
investigate these subjects
and be able to give an answer to
everyone that asketh them
the reason of the hope that is in them
now this sanctuary message
is the plan of redemption right and
it had to do with offerings for sin now
who became the great
offering for sin for us jesus jesus
christ
and it had the priest involved now who
became our high priest
jesus and what did he wrote the book of
hebrews say where did that high priest
enter
into the holy and then into the most
holy
correct so if you look at the sanctuary
as we have it depicted over here
there was this wall of white linen
around it and the bible tells us clearly
that the white linen stands for the
righteousness of christ
right and there was this one door
and jesus says i am the door
and there were you know a certain number
of pillars
and everything every detail is important
we're not going to do elections on the
sanctuary
but the very first thing you come across
is the altar of burnt offering so when
you entered into this
door which is christ you were
immediately
surrounded by this wall
of white linen that's the righteousness
of christ
and that's justification that's
justification covered by his
righteousness so
you accept christ you come to him
and the first thing you see is the altar
which stands for the cross
and there the lamb was slain which
stands for jesus christ
and his blood was placed upon the horns
of the altar
and the priest internalized a small
portion
after the sins had been transferred in
type
to the lamb by confession and the high
priest
bore the sin in type
on behalf of the sinner isn't that
incredible
amazing and then the next thing was the
labor
now when you accept the toning
sacrifice of christ when you realize you
are saved by his blood
then comes the washing of rebirth
so you go through the process of baptism
you died to the old man of self
and you rise up in a new life in christ
and it is no longer you that lives but
christ that lives in you
which basically means that your fallen
attributes
will be replaced by his yes unfallen
attributes and not because of any great
effort on your part
but because of his imputation what a
beautiful doctrine
and then that priest who would take
an offering for himself because he also
was a sinful human being
but christ was sinless
and he would take this offering his
blood
into the sanctuary just as much as the
priest here took it into the sanctuary
and there he would place it on the horns
of the altar so that the
record of all confessed sins
would be recorded there and
in this first compartment over here
there were
the candlestick yes the altar of
incense and the table of show bread
right
and they represent christ the light of
the world
and my word is the lamb
unto your feet yes and you have to
internalize this
he was the great mediator making your
prayers acceptable to god
reinstating the communication
that smoke that went up righteousness
going mingled with the prayers of the
saints
and then the body this is my body that
was given for you
internalize it internalize my character
the bread of life it's called
sanctification
in other words by the light of the word
communicate with me go and sin no more
and learn what it means to internalize
my character so that the world
can see the difference that's what
happens there
and then the most holy when you had
the ark of the covenant why is it called
most holy
because there's the basis of his
government the law
and above it was the mercy seat yes and
that was his throne
again represents christ and
and mercy in other words he shields you
from the condemnation of the law
he took it upon himself it is so
beautiful
that's amazing and we don't have time to
go into all the details but there is the
plan of salvation
you leave out any of those components
you are stuck on a quarter or halfway
road
so many want to come in and want to be
justified by christ
but what does it mean to repent
and forsake your sins what does it mean
to be
washed by the washing of rebirth
what does it mean to be sanctified by a
close
walk with jesus christ what does it mean
you have to study it and then all the
sacrifices that were brought and there
were sin offerings and there were
other offerings and and
it is it is a beautiful system and where
it
culminates by the ark with a
law just shows you the law wasn't taken
away
no it's put into the most most holy
so hebrews chapter 2 verse 3 says how
shall we
escape if we neglect so great salvation
which at the first began to be spoken by
the lord
and was confirmed unto us by them that
heard him so the study
of the self plan of salvation is it
important modern
yes we have to study it really important
is it possible to neglect so
great salvation yes yes yeah
is it possible to misunderstand so
greater salvation yes
if i'm not willing to let self
out of the way all right
so now we get to a rather complicated
issue
the issue of being without spot or
wrinkle
in the book of ephesians chapter 5 we
read
husbands love your wives even as christ
also loved the church
and gave himself for it so here he's
using a type
the relationship in a marriage and he
applies it to himself in the church
right
that he might sanctify and cleanse it
with the washing of
water by the word didn't we just see
that in the sanctuary
yes the light the candle thy
word is a lamp unto my feet and the
washing of water
which symbolizes the cleansing from sin
yes
the baptism that he might presented to
himself a
glorious church not having spot or
wrinkle
or any such thing but that it should be
holy
and without blemish
so reading these verses martin
who's doing the cleansing jesus
jesus right it's amazing he is doing
everything he's doing everything
even he is doing
the presenting to himself a glorious
church
so he's working everything you have to
let him all right so this church has to
be without
spot or wrinkle it must have
no blemish now he was the
the lamb without blemish right so in
other words this
church must reflect the righteousness of
christ christ
now this is where it gets tough yes
and this is where the debate has raged
through the centuries
and where the blood is flown in the
streets
nothing in this world is so dear to god
as his church with jealous
care he guards those who seek him
nothing so
offends god as for the servants of satan
to strive to
rob his people of their rights
the lord has not forsaken his people
satan points to the mistakes that they
have made
and tries to make them believe that thus
they have
separated themselves from god evil
angels seek in every way to discourage
those who
are striving for the victory of a sin
they hold up before them their past
unworthiness and
represent their case as hopeless
now martin i've been
a christian for 35 years
and i've seen so many young people
that feel hopeless their case is
hopeless
they've been some down some very dark
alleys
and they feel god cannot accept them
and satan is there to accuse right yes
he's there the whole time and then we
have
so many that have a doctrine that you
have to be without spot or blemish
and they look at themselves and they see
only spots
and blemishes and they despair
now what does it mean
to preach the gospel
isn't it mean to preach good news good
news
now is it good news to realize that you
are so blemished that you don't have a
hope
no no that's not good news that's bad
news right
so there's something twisted somewhere
out there
and we've got to get it into the right
perspective
so this is an issue that's going to
cause some ripples because if you take
one position
as i said before you're a legalist if
you take another person
position then you are in the category
that says
i'm not capable of not sinning but that
makes jesus a liar
and makes him a hard task master who
told you to go and sin no more
and knowing full well that you are
incapable of
doing what he commanded right it's not
logical you have to remain within the
realms of logic
so how do we deal martin with these
verses
romans 8 7 because the carnal mind
is enmity against god for it is not
subject to the law of god neither indeed
can be in other words
in my carnal nature i'm not subject to
the law of god
i'm a sinner i'm a transgressor of the
law
yeah and indeed i
cannot be subject to the law in other
words what this verse is saying
i cannot keep it right
but he said go and keep it yes
or what do we do with matthew 5 48 be ye
therefore perfect
even as your father which is in heaven
is perfect
there's another misnomer now you must be
perfect
and then you have 1 john 1 8 if we say
that we have no sin we deceive ourselves
and the truth is not in
us so here we have a dichotomy
we have the dichotomy of you have to be
perfect
as god himself the father is perfect
but if you say that you are without sin
you're a liar yeah
you're deceiving yourself
whenever you have two things that are
diametrically
opposed to each other in the scriptures
there must be something that makes them
common ground
right yes okay there's two things that
we can look at
one is maybe perfection
isn't the same as sinlessness
being without sin that's a possibility
right
and maybe to be perfect
and yet not to be without sin
can only be reconciled in christ
yes so if christ is perfect
as his father in heaven is perfect and
we know that he is
and if christ has no sin
then if he imputed to you that
righteousness and god sees
his righteousness rather than your state
then would you be perfect as your father
in heaven is perfect
yes in other words your imperfection
will have been
filtered out by the perfection of christ
and god will see you as perfect
because he's actually looking at the
righteousness but that doesn't
mean that you are without sin all right
let's look at it carefully two
possibilities or maybe both
possibilities
so we have to be perfect
as our father in heaven is perfect
that's a very high goal
and we may not say that we do not have
sin
that is a present tense
correct not the past tense not we had
no sin correct because some people say
okay but your sin has been forgiven now
you can be perfect
so it's present sin you have no sin
that's very very good point that you
mentioned there martin
so let's look at these verses in a
little bit more detail 1 john 1 6 if we
say that we have fellowship with him and
walk in darkness
we lie and do not the truth
doesn't say do not have the truth it
means do
not the truth but if we walk in the
light
as he is in the light we have fellowship
one with another and the blood
of jesus christ his son cleanses us
from all sin
if you are cleansed of all sin
then you are sinless right yes but he
says i may not say that i have no sin
because i am a sinner
but by decree he can declare me sinless
right
correct if we say we have
no sin we deceive ourselves and the
truth is
not in us so obviously
it's not in me to be sinless
it's only in him to be sinless right
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness
so is there something we must do yes
you must confess and
faith you must have faith yes
and if we say that we have not sinned we
make him a liar
and his word is not in us so we are
sinners sinners
nothing we can do about it correct but
uh
we can seek fellowship with him yes
so if we go to romans chapter 3 verse 23
it says for
all have sinned and come short of the
glory of god
so that's our condition right correct or
romans 5
12 wherefore as by one man sin
entered into the world and death by sin
and so
death passed upon all men for that
all have sinned we are all
in the same boat
so modern what we've discussed so far
in reality deals with moral depravity
is humanity capable of making a choice
or is it not capable of making a choice
that's the basis
if the doctrine of sin is based
on the law and its veracity
that by the law is the knowledge of sin
and sin is the transgression
of the law then if god requires
us to sin no more
then we must be able to make that choice
great because there are many people in
the world
where you can obviously see that they
haven't made that choice
right yes and there are many people that
claim to have made that choice
but don't actually live up to that
choice
and it's a very sad state
of affairs in the world that even
amongst
the best of the clergy in the world we
regularly in the media hear
of the tremendous transgressions of the
law that have taken place
under the cloak yeah yeah of
christianity
so the bible says by their fruits you
will
know they know them now
many a preacher has preached wonderful
sermons
and maybe brought many to christ
but when that preacher falls
he takes many away from christ as well
yeah
so the bible constantly warns us
do not look at the man correct
don't base your decision on the life of
a person
because we are fallible human beings
we could fall away tomorrow and history
is replete with people that have fallen
away
that doesn't change the fact that the
basis of the law
is go and sin no more yeah isn't that
correct
correct so now we have to deal with the
issue of
moral perfection and
it is an enormous task
and it'll take a while to go through
this
so let's see what we can do
so maybe it will be better to give us
enough time to get indeed
into it deep and do it justice
to do it in the following episode okay
so you're suggesting that we
close with the word of prayer please
okay
heavenly father we have just scratched
the surface
and there's so much more to say about
this issue
particularly when it comes to moral
perfection
and the final generation so help us in
our deliberations in jesus name
amen amen thank you for watching this
video
to subscribe click here when the bell
appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you